la gauche et la droite qui se sont
retrouvé côte à côte une fois n'est pas
coutume sur un terrain de football
François Hollande et Pierre Sarkozi dans
la même équipe un match était organisé
tout à l'heure en faveur de
l'association France Alzheimer hlenug
madidiawara ça va déjà bien échauffé cet
après-midi à l'Assemblée vous êtes prêt
monsieur bien prêt comme à l'Assemblée
les politiques change de costume vous
avez du XXL le terrain sportif pour la
bonne cause la lutte contre la maladie
d'Alzheimer une fois n'est pas coutume
gouvernement et opposition sous un même
maillot mais chacun aborde le match avec
l'esprit sporttif on joue ensemble je
crois donc quand même difficile de jouer
contre son camp donc on va on va pousser
dans le même sens bon on joue avec tout
le monde là dans une cause comme celle-l
on fait pas la différence on regarde pas
qui sont les transferts de l'année et
déjà un premier tacle aussitôt suivi
d'un autre j'essaierai peut-être à la
différence d'autres de ne pas marquer de
but contre mon camp oui viser leur
coéquipi Besson exsaliste entré au
gouvernement Fillon il joue en défense
je joue arrière-doit parce que le poste
d'arrière gauche n'était pas libre non
mais je je suis peut-être celui qui
effectivement connaî le plus de monde
dans l'équipe quoi autre surprise le
fils du chef de l'État pierre Sarkozi il
joue contre les politiques avec les
people et les sportifs ai parce que je
vais pas pouvoir rester trop longtemps C
on va remplacer Stéphane vous voulez
jouer en défense premier changement
décidé par l'entraîneur Gérard Rouillet
les socialistes entrent en
action ou 37
parmi les supporters Roseline Bachelot
est inquiète j'espère qu'on va pas avoir
trop de blessés espérons pour l'instant
déjà une moisson de but deux pour les
politiques qu pour leurs adversaires
grande gagnante la Fondation France
Alzheimer qui récolte 60000
€